What's up guys, Michael, here to talk about a wisecrack all time.
Favorite the office we've covered the pointless grind of working at a paper
company or the weird philosophical implications of Dwight K Schrute.
But today I'm here to talk to you about your boss and how they may or may not be
trying to convince you and,
or trick you into caring about your job and in doing so.
They might be a little more Michael Scott than you realize.
We'll explain in this wisecrack edition on Michael Scott and spoilers ahead for
the office.
At its core.
The office is a show about a workplace littered with people who kind of suck at
their jobs like an accountant who can't count.
This is a button.
Or a quality assurance rep who seems more down for crime than white collar work.
And while folks like Oscar and Angela seem competent enough,
it doesn't really matter because they're working for the King of incompetence.
Michael Scott.
I declare bankruptcy.
Of course.
The show later backtracks on that Utica.
Albany, all the other branches are struggling,
but your branch is reporting strong numbers.
Before double backtracking to show Michael's incompetence. Once again.
Sometimes I'll start a sentence and I don't even know where it's going.
I just hope I find it along the way.
Anyway, our useless workers are also joined by our unwilling workers.
People who could be good at their job if they gave even these slightest iota of
about what they do, their Stanley who passes time, napping,
Halloween.
He wears it. So we can sleep at his desk doing.
Crossword puzzles and dreaming of retirement,
or the disgrace to Ryan who doesn't do much of anything,
a strategy that eventually gets him thrown into a closet, enjoy it.
And of course, there's Jim slacker Supreme who pulls his coworkers,
even the motivated ones into a spiral of unproductive antics for much of the
early seasons.
He's excited about something like the office Olympics.
He gets really into it and he does a really great job.
But the problem with Jim is that he works here so that hardly ever
happens.
Smart. He just doesn't give a single.
Now some of this can all be chalked up to the pains of working in a bowl job,
a topic we've covered before,
but we actually think it's really interesting because it speaks to a centuries
old problem in business, getting people to show up and do their job.
This might shock you.
But showing up to work every day has never been an easy sell.
During the long dissolution of feudalism,
vagrancy laws were enacted to penalize anyone who wasn't vibing with the whole
getting a job thing. The goal, according to sociologist,
William Chambliss was to make sure that employers had access to cheap laborers
who literally could not turn down a job. After the industrial revolution,
bosses would struggle to a culture rate their employees to workplace practices
like not being faced at work,
showing up on time or even just showing up at all over the years,
toiling away in a horrible factories would rebel against their bosses by
deliberately sabotaging down their work,
doing their work poorly and not showing up. And if those workers were organized,
they just playing go on strike a collective version of not showing up that
sometimes involve fun signs and sometimes involve bombs and military
intervention. This doesn't really sound like the modern American workplace.
Of course, while absenteeism remains a problem,
most people show up on time or like five minutes late that's because we don't
have some ancestral farm to return to unlike Dwight.
And most of us would rather show up to a job, even if we hate it,
if only to keep the electricity on and then Netflix streaming.
But the problem isn't extinct people like Jim continued to Dick around all day
and corporations like Dunder Mifflin,
continue to try to stop them from doing so whether by enacting policies against
wasting time, time, thief, time, thief, fire him,
or Ty radically monitoring workers' comp.
He's not using crutches. Oh, get over the camera. Oh, worker's comp.
Really this whole struggle to get large groups of people to actually do their
jobs persist today and is way more interesting than you think.
And this is Michael Scott's basic quixotic mission to get his employees to care.
Whether that means desperately trying to keep up morale with bizarre.
Shows. Thank you all for coming to the 2005 Dundee.
Or inventing hyper-specific characters to get people to pay attention in
meetings,
but we can better understand the struggle like going back to the 1970s,
a real Renaissance period of not doing your job,
or at least doing it badly in the United States and Europe.
If today we live in a world where tons of people perform at least mediocrely at
work.
It's because of what happened in the aftermath of social upheaval in the late
1960s. A time when creed Bradon was still jamming with the grass roots,
this was when managers and the people who studied managers in the Western world,
especially France recognized a serious problem.
People were not showing up to work or were generally unmotivated when they did
that's according to sociologists, Luc Boltanski and Eve Capella,
who note that this coincided with an increase in strikes and even physical
violence against bosses. What's more,
they noticed that the quality of work was flagging due to workers,
severe lack of interest in their daily tasks.
Obviously this kind of sucks for a company's bottom line.
Jim is the perfect embodiment of this kind of worker,
the so-called ghost loads who even deliberately sabotaged their workplaces in
order to disrupt the daily grind that they load.
He does this every time he pranks twice.
Every time he screws with Michael and every time he distracts Pam AKA all day,
every day.
So how did we go from a world where everyone was Jim in it up to one where
people check their work emails after a fun Saturday night out with a little
thing called Neo management. And even though he does a pretty bad job at it,
Michael Scott is the perfect embodiment of this philosophy. Michael Scott,
as a manager is a response to everything people initially against in the late
sixties and seventies as well. Tans can Chappelle note,
nobody wanted to be a suit or sell out to the man.
And this image of stuffy corporate types had a lot to do with the push to make
workplaces as scientific as possible. They describe how in the 1960s,
there was a transition away from small nepotistic firms and family run
businesses to larger company that required professional legions of managers to
run properly.
But these larger companies also felt soulless people were not engaged with or
motivated by their work. So companies faced with this problem started to adapt.
And especially in the 1990s, they really started to Michael Scott it up.
Basically it was believed that workplace hierarchies and the resultant dominant,
dominated relations, they inspired were harmful.
And even a moral Michael seems to have internalized this message.
You may look around and see two groups here,
white collar, blue collar, but I don't see it that way. And you know, why not?
Because I am color blind.
It's a world you might be familiar with.
Many workplaces lost their rigid hierarchy.
They stripped the visible signs of power from those in charge to convince lowly
workers that their managers are just they're lovable pals.
People that you work with are just when you get down to it,
your very best friend.
And this, if nothing else is the Michael Scott ethos in a nutshell,
but taken majorly to the extreme from the very opening moments of the show is
pilot Michael's. Number one, emo has been simple.
Get the people in his workplace to adore him and thus adore their jobs too.
Would I rather be feared or loved? Um, easy both.
I want people to be afraid of how much they love it.
What's actually really brilliant about the office is that by doing this,
they took a real workplace phenomenon. In fact,
a defining phenomenon amongst this era of managers and turned it into Michael's
number one, personality flaw,
Michael's drive maybe a little more self-centered than just make money,
but the result is very much the same.
Your boss might slightly try to empower you with a grand vision of your
organization's noble goals or worse dress up your dull workplace with birthday
parties, a ping pong table. And he very Jiff heavy company Slack,
and it might work.
But Michael Scott is iconic for just how plainly he shows the reality of these
poultry attempts at boosting worker engagement through his own incompetence.
He tries to buy ice cream sandwiches after everyone's healthcare was just
slashed and throws a murder mystery party to distract from bankruptcy rumors
across the board.
His attempt to spin his coworkers into family is so amazingly cringe-worthy
because they're so clearly not.
What's more as bolt-ons ski and chia pelo note,
the new era of managers do not seek to supervisor give orders.
They have understood that such roles are outmoded. They become team leaders,
catalysts, visionary coaches, sources of inspiration.
This is the description that fits Michael Scott to a T as the show is littered
with talking heads of him aspiring to be some kind of weirdo. Thought-leader.
Reverse. Psychology is an awesome tool. I don't know if you guys know about it,
but basically you make someone think the opposite of what you
believe and that tricks them into doing something stupid.
Well, at first it seems like pure madness.
When we understand it in the context of Neo management,
suddenly he makes sense he's doing what many other managers at the time were
supposed to be doing.
He's just taking it to the nth degree and also really sucking at it in this era.
According to bolt-ons kinship, Capello managers also started to stress,
creativity to combat the whole dehumanizing meat grinder aspect of work.
It's a problem we can see with people who've absent,
any real creative agency and their job turned to art or the art of pranks.
The problem of making your job feel more creative is one even managers suffer
from. And we see Michael coping in a myriad of ways by recreating an episode of
survivor, man writing his own movie,
making his own commercial or dressing up like Willy Wonka for a harebrained
promotion. Michael doesn't want his workplace to be some inhuman meat grinder,
which is why it pains him so much to fire anyone.
Oh man. Okay. I have to fire somebody.
Or put a family paper company out of business. My heart says no.
It's why he insisted his constant fun distractions are good for his workers.
It's also why he responds so negatively to Charles miner,
a manager with experience in the old school steel industry.
That probably doesn't value creativity as much as your new social media startup.
Interestingly enough, the office debuted in 2005,
just about a decade after these ideas were percolating. In fact,
to be technical,
Michael Scott was still in the early days of his Dunder Mifflin career,
as the discourse really started going down.
And so it makes sense that he embodies the entire ethos just way to a
fault.
Whereas good Neo managers attempted to connect with their workers on a personal
level.
Michael Scott's attempts at familiarity are constantly straining relationships,
driving evil,
absolutely bananas and actively disrupting their focus from getting too involved
in people's relationships to trying to force an employee into rehab.
[Inaudible].
To defining the sexuality of another employee and then outing him to the whole
office.
Who's gay. And who's not, of course. What about Oscar? Absolutely not.
He is.
In one telling episode,
we literally learn what we basically already knew that Michael's antics far from
fostering.
A healthy workplace are actually the single greatest cause of stress in his
employees.
Let me just step back, please. We'll further. Okay.
Of course.
As much as Michael tries to convince everyone that they're a family of equals,
there is still a hierarchy at the office.
Michael Scott is the boss still.
Even when he does boss stuff like making everyone attend wildly inefficient
group meetings, it's always for the greater purpose of getting closer to them.
But while he might spend his time pretending he's everyone's friend,
it takes Stanley openly define him to reveal that at the end of the day,
Michael is in charge. Even if, again, he's not very good at it.
This was a fake firing.
Now Neil management thinkers encountered a another growing problem in the
nineties. Workers also just didn't want creativity.
They wanted purpose a fat paycheck. Wasn't enough.
People wanted to know they were making a difference or changing the world.
That's why every dumb,
new social network startup will brag about connecting the world and making
people's lives better. It's a struggle.
I'm sure many of you watching this deal with, as you ask questions,
like why toil away at a job until I'm old and spiritually dead inside a
question familiar to both Pam and Jim. I said, I don't think.
It's many little girl's dream to be a receptionist.
It's a problem. Framed at the top of the show with Jim's first talking to him.
My job is to speak to clients, um, on the phone about,
uh, quantities and, uh,
type of copier paper.
Basically Jim's job is a Orin and be pointless.
And even after Michael has gone the way the show ends up with a happily ever
after is to give Jim a job that is fun,
but able to retroactively give his time at Dunder Mifflin a purpose.
It was all worth it. You see,
because Jim built a family and even married his co-worker,
his final talking head here, mirrors his opening.
One only with the added purpose of love.
My job was to speak to clients on the phone about quantities and types of
copier paper. Even if I didn't love every minute of it,
everything I have, I owe to this job.
Heartwarming stuff,
but it's ultimately fitting that Jim's arc is to land a job that allows him to
be creative while the details about his new job are vague.
We know that he gets a job with athlete,
a sports marketing company that is allegedly more creatively fulfilling than the
paper business. He gets to play ball with his heroes, read their bad screenplay.
Megan,
I was too shy to tell you this when I was just a normal professional baseball
player, but I love you.
And work in a place with poorly placed basketball hoops,
AKA Neo management done, right? But back to Michael,
while he fails to instill creativity and purpose in the workplace,
the thing he's really trying to do is again in aggressively real phenomenon,
see all the creativity and purpose can often hide another truth.
Your boss can't pay you more. So how else do they get you to work harder?
Reading modern day management literature.
You may not be surprised to learn that things like unlimited vacation days save
companies money because you take less of them.
And perks like snacks are often valued by employees, more than cash.
In other words, I'd rather take a job that paid $5,000 less.
If I got $500 of compute, HSA and unlimited cold brew on tap. See,
as the economy changed,
work became more competitive and opportunities to rise in ranks of your company.
Shrink significantly.
This loss of hierarchy meant less manager type positions to move up into and
companies always looking to increase their profit margin. Look,
to get more out of people for less, as a result,
your manager couldn't always use the motivation of a raise or a real promotion.
We see this very plainly when Michael gives Dwight and in name only promotion,
which functionally does nothing to change his job or pay rate.
I am promoting you from assistant to the regional manager to assistant regional
manager.
Another way managers make workers feel motivated is by assigning their
underlings tasks that are actually managerial work to make them feel more
valued.
Think of that time when Michael at Dwight picked their new healthcare plan for
that matter, Dwight regularly takes on managerial tasks,
responding to Michael's lack of days with overly fervent,
supervising these strategies are all part of a larger attempt to get you to
emotionally engaged with your job and the people you work with,
but are there risks to this?
I eat what happens when your boss does have an emotional hold over you because
rest assured Michael in spite of his very alienating methods,
certainly does have that emotional hold over.
At least some of his workers Dwight would literally kill for him.
And one of the shows most memorable moments is when Pam leaves Dunder Mifflin to
follow Michael on his quest to form his own paper company.
This reflects a real effect of good Neo management,
which is that people get a new kind of investment in their job.
The investment of as noted Bible Todd's kinship, hello,
not only their technical skills, but also their creativity,
their sense of friendship, their emotionalism, and so on.
I E your full self.
This can though does not always result in one of your coworkers being your best,
man.
I can't believe that's what you said.
So what gets lost when your work life disappears into your lifeline new
risks of exploitation,
according to our friendly management birds and that's concerning because Neal
management has been widely propagated, which is to say,
Michael Scott's don't happen in a vacuum.
And his bizarre behavior is evidence of something very real in this way.
The office actually functions as a really good case study of why your boss
shouldn't feel like you're family. Because when that happens,
it's a whole lot easier for your work to become your life. Now,
I'm not saying you can't like your boss and then sometimes getting the invites
to his elaborate dinner parties. Isn't dope.
It's disgusting.
And there's plenty of great bosses who will stand up for their employees and to
all the managers at Omnia media and enthusiast gaming.
I love you no matter what I just said, you're my family.
But if we look at all those other companies,
we can see how Neo management tactics,
whether it's playing call of duty for team-building or holding a spirited beat,
shad competition for promotions are almost uniformly designed to blur the
personal professional line.
But the next time your boss tries to act like a family member,
ask yourself what he or she is really trying to do. It's possible.
They're just trying to get more work out of you for the same amount of money,
but what do you guys think is the office a wholesome tale about workplace unity
or a secretly kind of sinister look at what happens when the boundaries between
work and real life learn beyond recognition.
Let us know in the comments slam that subscribe button in half,
like at your company's ping pong paddle, and be sure to ring that bell big,
thanks to our patrons for your support, and as always,
thanks for watching later.
[Inaudible].